my guess this week is a civil rights
attorney legal expert and you may have
seen us on dr. Drew's couch together
hurry the Martin welcome to the show
good to be here you know from sitting
next to each other to sitting across
from each other yeah this is it seems
that we're gonna be adversaries because
we're usually on a couch right next to
each other we get some leg touch that
helps with some of the crazies that come
on that show and really make it
difficult for people I think like you
and I who have really intelligent and
smart things to say yeah Wow where we're
building each other up just as we start
here but that's exactly why I wanted to
have you on the show because we've been
on dr. drew a couple times together and
I always find you you know you're
extremely passionate and you know your
stuff and I find there's so many people
in television especially in cable news
and on the cable channels that are just
yelling and screaming about stuff but
aren't really experts I can tell you and
not to brag about my background but you
know when your regular expert you really
want the person I have some credentials
that really make them an expert and I
can't tell you how many times on these
shows I've sat next to someone I'm
having a conversation I want to go you
know what I'm sorry is yeah it just
drives me crazy but yes there's been a
proliferation of quote-unquote experts
because there's so many shows and it
seems like if you're willing to say
something so outrageous and to say it
very loudly you can get booked on a show
yeah and that's what we see pretty
routinely on a lot of these shows yeah
and that is again I mean that's why I
love working with you because not only
do you know your but you get right
to it
sometimes I'm sitting there and I'm
thinking man if I just had that kind of
just incisive way of going at it so
we're gonna get into some some pretty
yeah well I've been working on TV for a
while and I've had to perfect the
soundbite as often times you got 30
seconds yeah and I tell you I start
checking the news at 5
I read seven eight newspapers throughout
the day and I'll get a call and it's
some complex issues that I've got to go
on and talk to millions of viewers to
make them understand
sometimes very technical legal stuff and
the reality is what's happening in a
courtroom in a difficult case a murder
trial doesn't really play well when
you're trying to reduce it to a
30-second sound bite so you got to get
kind of skilled and how to bring that
very complex information to really
digestible television viewers yeah and
that's exactly why I like doing the
long-form interview because now we have
an hour or maybe a little bit more even
to really get into some stuff really
exchange some ideas so important because
some of these topics are so big you can
literally spend all day talking about
but yet you've got to reduce it to a
soundbite so yeah I love long-form
conversations all right then we're in
the right spot but before we get to the
issues I want to do a little bit on your
history so you are you're from st. Louis
originally was right next to Ferguson
Missouri so when we were all eyes on
Ferguson with the Mike Brown shooting it
was really personal for me because not
only did I grow up in that community I
knew so many of the people that were
involved on the front lines during the
protests so when that happened when that
explosion in that community occurred
really personally for me so yes from st.
Louis and went to college in Chicago
University of Chicago love Chicago glad
I'm not there this weekend though even
you know the blizzard that's been just
you know ravishing the company country
yeah you moved the right direction to
the sunshine exactly and then when I
went to Harvard so I lived in Cambridge
unfortunately the Patriots aren't going
to the Patriots but uh yes I went to
Harvard then I actually worked in a
corporate law firm I worked on Wall
Street and I was in this major corporate
law firm representing big fortune 500
companies and doing a lot of corporate
law and I just got tired I just it
didn't fit with my background didn't fit
with you know who I had grown up to be
and the people that had influenced me so
I left I left this really really really
really
really really good job yeah are you
saying the corporate lawyers make a lot
of money is that what I'm saying I left
a good job a lot of money and a lot of
perks and office like on the 40th floor
big it was amazing yeah so imagine me
calling st. Louis the family that's like
just over the moon with happiness that
first generation college graduate first
generation Harvard lawyer big corporate
law firm and now I'm leaving to go work
with one other lawyer in this tiny
little office on Wilshire Boulevard in
Los Angeles yeah give up this huge
salary it didn't go over too well you
must have felt incredible pressure
because you had sort of accomplished a
lot not not that advanced of an age and
then you say alright I'm gonna step away
from the walk but isn't that sort of
what it's all about really I think it is
and I think folks who find the most
happiness and their careers it's because
they've taken a risk and they really
follow their instincts they follow their
intuition they don't do what's on the
kind of the path that's been laid out
for them and and if you go to Harvard
and you're in the top of your class your
path is supposed to be either you become
a Supreme Court Clerk right and you go
on to be a judge or you go and you run a
corporate law firm you start off as an
associate you become a partner and you
make a ton of money and that's a great
life and having lots of friends that do
that so I'm not saying there's anything
wrong they throw a good party they they
have great lifestyles but it just wasn't
who I was at my core I wanted to have
more control over who I represented I
wanted to represent little people I
wanted to be involved in issues that
really matter to me and I just wanted
something different from my career so I
had no husband had no mortgage and no
kids so you could walk away from a big
job like that when you don't have all of
those responsibilities yeah and now you
have a husband oh my god you have a law
firm that you run with your husband
correct yes and you have three kids and
all of this stuff so you're doing a lot
of stuff yeah
but I'm happy about it and about seven
years ago I decided I wanted to step
away from my courtroom practice I was a
trial lawyer and I wanted to have a
greater impact and I had this amazing
case amazing because I was representing
these great families horrible thing that
happened to them their kids had been
abused in the classroom some nonverbal
autistic kids abused in the classroom by
this just criminal teacher really and
they called me from Las Vegas and asked
me to come and represent them and I did
that and dr. Phil was very interested in
their story mm-hmm and invited my
clients and then me as a result of
representing them onto his show and I
got there I loved having an opportunity
to raise awareness about an issue I
cared about and break down you know what
had happened legally and why this
teacher was being prosecuted and that
began my TV career and I've been working
in TV ever since that one appearance on
dr. fields yeah and even that we're
gonna get to this a little later but
even having a case involving autism
you've written a book about autism your
son has autism yes I don't like saying
is autistic because it is very it seems
very defining versus has autism it's
just a piece of who he is so that even
that right there is a nice way to start
your adventure sort of because it was
something that was very important to you
yeah and you're right I did write a book
because I was frustrated I didn't like
what was out there it was too hard to
figure out how do you get the best
education how do you get the best health
care and I said this is crazy
I'm a harvard-trained lawyer and I'm
having such a difficult time what about
the mom who has four or five kids at
home maybe working two jobs and doesn't
have the time to sit on an Internet all
day like I did and search for this
information so I wrote a book called the
everyday advocate standing up for your
child with autism and other special
needs to really bring a lot of the
information that I had learned as a
parent and as an advocate and as a
lawyer into one place that a parent a
professional could go and get the help
that they need for their child
grandchild or whatever so really just
tried to make that journey a little
easier for parents okay all right well
we're gonna dive a little deeper into
that in a bit but let's knock out some
issues okay so you already brought up
first thing that I want to discuss with
you which is black lives matter okay so
as you said you're from st. Louis right
that's the Ferguson who know this area a
couple weeks ago I had Larry elder Ahn
who is I roll already was that side I or
I roll there was a little bit on his
radio show we've debated these issues a
lot I don't understand Larry to be
honest with you bright guy lawyer yeah a
turn talk show host radio talk show host
but his views are the most extreme views
I can't even imagine where he got them
from so so I don't want to I don't want
to make this about him it's not
necessary but the reason I mentioned it
is because why I like doing the show is
I want to talk to people that believe
one thing and somebody that believes
something else so that's a great place
for us to start because basically his
take I don't want to put words in his
mouth but to paraphrase him was he felt
that there really is no more systemic
racism in the United States and that the
really the the struggle for the black
community is because of the breakdown of
the family so if you want to address
that a little bit then we can dive right
in to really be more articulate about it
but I'm just gonna say that stupid to
say there's no longer systemic racism
just ignores so much data so many
statistics as so many reports just it
ignores the facts it ignores the reality
and conservatives like Larry like to
deflect from those issues because if
they can blame it on the family if they
can blame it on the victims and they
don't have to accept any responsibility
but the reality is the criminal justice
system let's just start there
disproportionate number of African
Americans and Latinos but particularly
blacks who are incarcerated who have
longer sentences who are treated
differently everything from driving
while black so who are racially profiled
even when they drive their cars and
we've seen so many examples of this from
high-profile people like Chris Rock yeah
James Blake the tennis player
who
all have had some negative experience
the president yeah are colder when he
was Attorney General talked about him
and his brother being stopped in in
Washington so Danny Glover something
happened with Danny Glover he couldn't
get a cab or something I don't think
there's denta fie a black man really
serious whether they're high profile
celebrity professional or just the guy
on the street that hasn't had some
negative experience with the police
simply because of their race so when
folks like Larry talked about you know
we're posting racial society the facts
are off that's wrong so what would you
say about the family part though because
there does it seems to me that as I say
on the show all the time two things can
be true at once so everything that
you've said there fully make sense to me
but also that the breakdown of the
family in general
black white asian green is is a problem
that we had well I don't know what he
means when he says the breakdown of the
family I think families have changed so
let's talk about two gay individuals who
are now parents because they can get
married they can adopt a kid don't go
too deep oh well okay what the reality
is the family today isn't the family of
the 1950s so when they say the breakdown
of the family what family are they
talking about single moms are as common
as two family households you know we
just say that that's a better family
structure so I'm not sure even I buy
into that assertion that there's been
some breakdown I will agree there's been
an evolution and families look very
different today interracial families
couldn't exist 4050 years ago is that
the breakdown of the family because now
you and I could be married and have kids
yeah is that no longer you know what
that could be the new thing okay though
but you and I could decide to have a
child together right sure even though
we're not married you in vitro I mean
there's so many ways that families are
created so when they say that breakdown
what are they talking about so I don't
buy into that yeah all right so let's
dive in really into into black lives
matter as a movement what do you make of
the general movement
itself do you feel that it's it's
hitting the right tone I'm going to say
this and I'm gonna get just slaughtered
on social media Twitter right oh my god
somehow I become like the spokesperson
for black lives matter even though you
know they haven't enlisted me they
haven't called me on the phone and asked
me to do it but I find myself trying to
give some context I think what black
lives matter has done has been nothing
short of brilliant the issue of race and
race politics in this country very
complex and all hands on deck so I play
a role as a civil rights attorney that
represents families who have been the
victims of any kind of police violence
or they've had their rights violate the
constitutional right so I step in as a
lawyer and I represent those people but
then I have this platform we get the
talk on television every week about
these high-profile cases so I get to
lend my voice of that then there these
people who go out and they march and
they protest and look as a result of
that so folks in the courtroom folks
using their platform on television folks
like Al Sharpton using his voice and
then these protesters so now the issue
of police profiling police shootings of
african-americans it's been elevated to
this national level black lives matter
have had audiences with Hillary Clinton
Bernie Sanders it's come up in the
presidential debate and I think we've
got to give those protestors some credit
for that because but for their activism
this issue would not have become a part
of the national dialogue that we're
having about how do we make communities
safer yeah what did you make of the
instance when the two protesters went up
to Bernie's podium and basically grabbed
the mic from I mean sort of let them do
it because a lot of people felt that
that was like you know I talk about
identity politics a lot and that my
problem with identity politics is I find
everyone has to figure out who's the
most aggrieved
so you're autumn bernie is an ally
obviously of the black lives matter
movement he's an ally of the other
always but if everyone is always looking
out just for themselves then you
have the right in your mind to grab the
mic away from him who even though he's
as left as it's gonna get in France in
America now to say that I support what
black lives matter has done in terms of
elevating this conversation to a
national level doesn't mean I agree with
everything that you're sure what I like
for them to approach Bernie differently
yeah did I feel good about watching him
try to figure out what do i do do I call
security do I have them escorted and
then kind of what's unfair about that
yeah he didn't have Secret Service
protection the reality is they wouldn't
have even gotten here that microphone or
stage had that been Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump or any of the other
candidates that Trump has Secret Service
but he has plenty of security so the
reality is Bernie in allowing himself to
be open kind of left himself open to
these hyper protesters I didn't like
that yeah bottom line I didn't like that
but it doesn't to me take away from the
overall efforts that they've had and the
successes that they've had but I do
think that we have to get comfortable
with this concept of disruption mm-hmm
and that's what I think is so upsetting
to a lot of people even African
Americans even traditional African
American civil rights leaders they want
black lives matter to fit into this box
yeah they want them to follow the mold
of the 1950s and 1960s protesters and
they're like hell no that's not who we
are we're not looking for Martin Luther
King to come and save us and to lead us
this is a movement of the people from
the people and it's being done totally
different so they they're not looking to
organize in a way that John Lewis and a
lot of those civil rights leaders did
and I think that's a little unsettling
for people they don't get it yeah so
that's an interesting sort of
generational struggle because obviously
John Lewis and Martin Luther King and
Malcolm X and many other people did
things at different levels some on the
ground some via speaking and all that
and I find that this movement hasn't
quite figured out what it is yet but I
think your point is that that's part of
that's part of it part of the magic
that's the part
this new paradigm that literally you can
go on Twitter and organize a thousand
people to show up at a rally and
sometimes at that rally and my daughter
has been so there was a big rally last
year after Thanksgiving in Los Angeles
and she says mom
some people had this sign some people
had that sign there was really no
organization I'm not even sure if people
knew why they were there but he caught
fire on Facebook it caught fire on
Twitter and thousands of people showed
up yeah and I says well you have to get
used to that that's a part of the
unorganized nature of it is what makes
it special and what makes it unique and
yes some people were there for gay
rights some people were there for human
rights some people were there for sex
trafficking some people were there for
police brutality done I said but they
were all people who at the end of the
day just trying to make their lives
their communities the people they care
about have a better quality of life so
for that I have to apply so
interestingly there could be sort of
this could be the genesis of something
sort of much bigger because when you
take all those people and again this is
where my thing with identity politics is
sort of interesting because everyone's
got their issues yes and yet they're
coming together so that's good in itself
yeah
but I'm afraid that that it allows for a
lot of issues to then just jump on top
of each other when some of these things
aren't necessarily connected but but
what's the alternative
and that's what I say to people okay you
don't like how black lives matter has
addressed this police brutality issue
which by the way you you have to give
them some credit for all of the the
legislation that's happening at the
federal level and state by state
requiring body cams California just
passed the law now that says a special
prosecutor has to be appointed if there
is a police shooting so we have seen the
fruits of their labor and I say to
people give me an alternative what what
in your world view it or if you could
you know wave a magic wand how would it
look yeah here yeah I yeah I don't think
you're asked no I'm with you I I got him
there philosophically there's something
to me that seems a little dangerous of
everyone sort of jumping on these
social be social justice things but but
I do hear you I do hear ya I don't I
don't see anyone else and the black
lives matter protesters that you talk
about generation yeah they said al
Sharpton and some of these other civil
rights movements leaders what they do
was fine yeah terrible they they really
are about grassroots they're by local
people indigenous leadership so people
in their own communities standing up and
demanding that they get a voice at the
table when decisions are being made like
who's going to be the police chief who's
going to be the District Attorney now
what I would say is what I hope to see
and I was disappointed in the midterm
elections last time how do we translate
all of this social activism into
electoral politics how do we get those
thousands of people that showed up for a
rally how do we get them to vote right
and I know you I see an election and
Beyond yeah and you talked a lot about
local politics so I can backing up for a
sec I can't give you an example where I
think it's a bit of a problem so for
example what we're seeing on college
campuses right now with free speech now
I get that the the thrust of what
they're doing they're standing up for
social justice and they want equality
we're not just talking about the black
community the gay community whoever it
is so I understand the idea there but
then when you see the instances like at
Yale where they're shouting down this
professor and that they're you know
they're demanding professors be fired it
seems to me that we've created a
situation here where the students are
now dictating the policy which seems a
little backwards and I know that there's
a lot of people in academia that are
that are really afraid of where this is
headed but they're 18 they're 19 and
think about what what what should you be
doing at college I think what those
students are doing well you should be
exchanging ideas but not demanding that
professors be fired well why not if the
professors are erases and the professors
are all not sensitive to the issue of
inclusion and diversity why not yeah
they'd be fired did you feel that that
professor at Yale the the he was the
Dean of that that college and his wife
had written a letter about the Halloween
costumes I mean to me it was just you
know if they don't want to okay yes here
a problem for me in any transition
anytime you're trying to transform an
organization that has has systemic
racial inequality and injustice is for
decades is somebody going to get is
somebody gonna be sacrificed that
perhaps really wasn't the person are
they gonna be scapegoated probably yeah
but why is a university like the
University of Missouri that all
predominately black football team if
they hadn't stood up and stood with the
guy Jonathan Butler who went on the
hunger strike if they hadn't stood up
with those students I doubt if Jonathan
would still be on that hunger strike
I'll be dead by now I doubt it that you
right so in that case nobody responded
right so but but why is a public
university like Missouri like 7% five
four since such a low percentage of
african-american students why does it
take us to get to the point where the
students have to shout down the
professors for the universities that
look at themselves the same there's
something wrong with this picture it's
not reflective of the community where
this school is and and you remember that
University of Missouri president he's in
his parade and he was so arrogant and he
wouldn't even address those students so
did he did he end up stepping down yeah
so interestingly the the Missouri and
the Yale ones which happened basically
at the same time I see as to what to me
at the Yale thing was was far worse than
his everything yeah had the mostly black
football teams not got involved then
nothing would have happened so I do hear
that but even in that instance you know
there was that professor or part-time
professor that woman who came out and
got caught on camera saying some muscle
here and then that is that is a free
speech issue so I guess that goes to
your earlier point which is you can be
for a movement and that doesn't mean you
agree with every every tactic some of
the tactics are not well thought out but
again that's why I said they're 18
they're 19 you know this is their first
some of them first experience with any
kind of unrest or any kind of protest so
I wouldn't expect their thoughts to be
as developed yeah well their tactics to
be as developed as you know somebody
30 or 40 or beyond so I think we have to
just accept that these are teenagers
just kind of finding their way and young
adults who are finding their way on some
pretty complex issues but I think more
importantly for me is if I'm a
university president why why are I being
more proactive on these issues why
aren't I addressing issues of diversity
and inclusion before it bubbles up and
now I have the kind of protest that
we've seen on campuses across this
country I just don't think a lot of
these folks have being very smart about
the issue of diverse diversity and
inclusion and we could segue into the
Oscars yeah very good example yeah on
that let me throw in one other thing and
then we'll go Oscar but this is exactly
why I wanted to talk about this because
I think that basically the the bulk of
the singing people in the middle of this
country pretty much see these things in
a similar way but even just what we're
doing right now it shows that there are
there are different ways of looking at
it doesn't mean someone else is racist
or someone else is automatically a bigot
or something and we're so used to using
those words so that's that's why I agree
that's why I wanted to unfurl some but
sometimes unfortunately we can't sit
down yeah well that's why I got a
dialogue because those words that you
use just shuts the conversation down
yeah so one other piece on this and then
we'll move to the Oscars is my guest
last week Michael Shermer who's a
thinker and a skeptic he made an
interesting point about the college
thing where he said to me you know if
these kids at Yale if at this point what
they're protesting about is Halloween
costumes that might offend them then
that actually shows great progress in
society because of the things that they
would have had to protest 30 years ago
and I thought that actually gave me a
little bit of it was a nice feeling to
sort of take away from this that it
doesn't mean that problems don't exist
but it means that we actually have moved
forward in society and we don't I think
sometimes we don't stop and acknowledge
that yeah and I think Obama did a great
job of that when they had the march on
the John Pettis bridge at Selma and he
says as much work as there is to do on
this question of race in America we
cannot lose sight of the tremendous
progress that has
so I would agree with Michael and that
point that yes they weren't protesting
because they couldn't eat in the same
cafeteria or drink from the same water
fountain as the white students now the
issues of race and they've changed they
are they're more subtle they're more in
some ways insidious because they're not
overt so the colored only signs made it
real clear right what what our mission
was you know there wasn't much dispute
about that but now you're right because
even again African Americans are often
divided on this question and I've sat on
Drew's couch with some conservative
African Americans who say like Larry
what are they complaining about yeah
they were in the College work hard get
good grades and everything will work out
so that people aren't you know speaking
from one voice on this issue of race
because it's complex yeah so I know I
said last thing what I'm going to throw
in one word just jumping on that so what
are you making general of of black
conservatives because I'm friends with a
few black conservatives David Webb who's
Sirius XM host who is a Fox News
contributor is a good friend of mine we
work together it's serious and I know
that he I know him extremely well and I
you know we've had drinks together we've
had dinner together I know that he
believes what he's saying yeah and and
when I see what people say about him
online you know Uncle Tom and Jesse we
could go through the yeah the list of
things that people say what do you make
of people like that well first of all I
think David and any black Republican
conservative however they identify
themselves they're perfectly within
their right to have the opinions that
they have about race and politics and to
identify with the GOP party or the
independent party or whatever party so I
don't come from a place that because
you're black you have to agree with
everything that I believe in or because
you're gay or you know there's no
monolithic thought in any of these
communities that people have different
points of views and I like a
conversation where all of those points
of views have an opportunity to present
themselves and to be a part of the
conversation I don't think that because
David or Larry or any of those
conservatives have their view about the
family that that
view is any less significant than my
view yeah because I don't see it the way
they see it doesn't mean that their
points aren't important so I like
debating those guys I like talking to
those guys and I think it's a mistake to
try to shut their speech down or to try
to silence them yeah - wait the silence
you know some people call these lefties
these you know super progressives all
right so no I
yeah I'm not thrilled with those guys
either